okay we have a voicemail number the
number is two one nine two david p that
for people who aren't able to translate
that into numbers i want to mention that
the number is two one nine two three two
eight four three seven you can call it
any time of day here's a voicemail about
an issue that also I look for forward to
opportunities to clarify on other
programs and it is about whether the US
is the worst or not on our coronavirus
response table ISM we we obviously we
have the worst record of anybody we have
one third of the deaths one third of the
cases of the whole planet there's no
doubt that were the worst the world
there's absolutely no doubt okay so
here's where I am on this I I don't know
that the United States coronavirus
response has been the worst in the world
and I've been careful not to say that
it's been one of the worst and if you
say who had the worst responses slowest
most propagandistic suppressing data not
testing you know all this different
stuff from the countries we know of that
have had a bunch of cases the United
States is certainly on the list of the
worst Brazil is on the list of the worst
India seems to be on that list Russia is
on the list of the worst responses you
know I've heard anecdotally that
Turkmenistan had a terribly
propagandistic totalitarian response I
just don't know enough about that and
it's a very small country so you know it
could be difficult sometimes to glean
everything we want to clean North Korea
is thrown around but here's where I
think we need to shift the conversation
on this instead of arguing is the u.s.
the worst or are we like fifth worst or
tenth worst or 20th worst what happened
to American exceptionalism what happened
to the people who say and believe the US
should be the best at everything we
certainly were not the best and we
weren't second best or third best or
fourth best so let's shift the debate
from are we really the worst or just bad
- why are we now using that as a
standard since when is the standard in
the United States from those who
subscribe to the idea of American
exception
since when is the standard have we
avoided being the worst the standard has
always been are we the best and no one
can argue that we are the best merely
looking at South Korea Taiwan Japan
Greece you know even a bunch of European
countries we're certainly not in the top
ten I would argue we are in the worst
ten and all of a sudden the debate is
are we aren't we the worst that was
never the debate if you believe in
American exceptionalism do not let them
hijack that conversation we have a great
bonus show for you today
producer Pat Forde will be joining me I
also want to remind you Monday Memorial
Day Monday Memorial Day we are doing a
one-day membership kablooie as I am
calling it membership kablooie to take
us back to the days of Warner Brothers
cartoons we will email everybody on our
mailing list on Monday with a one-day
coupon code which will give you an
absolutely disgusting discount off of
membership so if you've been thinking of
getting a membership but haven't yet
kind of waiting around for that
opportunity Monday Memorial Day is the
opportunity be notified on Monday by
signing up for our mailing list at david
pakman.com upper right of the website
you type in your email address I'm doing
my typing motion type in your email
address and then Monday you will get
that email with this just I mean it's
it's a vial coupon code quite frankly
you would be shocked when you see it
that does it for today on the bonus show
we will talk about UK citizens being
designated organ donors by default very
interesting story we will talk about
some gyms starting to reopen despite the
fact that they aren't supposed to yep I
will give you an update on my gym I
think we will hear from Pat about his
gym and we also now are getting an
apology from Republican Georgia Governor
Brian Kemp because lo and behold it's
not just Florida the Georgia website
incorrectly showed a downward trend in
coronavirus infections which was not
accurate all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show I'll see you then